okay we obviously covered this insane
Donald Trump story last week where he
said that President Obama founded Isis
was the founder of Isis Kyle kolinsky /
secular talk followed up on it with a
story we didn't cover and this is about
Democratic Senator Claire McCaskill sort
of trying to turn the tables on that
idea but according to some not doing it
in a way that was a very positive thing
let's go to kyles clip we'll watch that
and then I'll give you my thoughts
Democratic Senator Claire McCaskill went
on Fox News Sunday and she responded to
Donald Trump claiming Obama founded Isis
let's watch I mean he isn't criticizing
her in any way denigrating the work of
the military he's saying that President
Obama and Hillary Clinton made some bad
decisions that have led to the present
situation well you can there's a lot of
reasons that Isis rose up one of them
was a Status of Forces Agreement known
as sofa that Bush negotiated we couldn't
leave our troops in Iraq even if the
president wanted to because the
Parliament in Iraq was refusing to give
them immunity now Trump probably thinks
the sofa the status of forces agreement
is a gilded couch at marlow go he
probably doesn't even know what sofa is
but that was a very relevant part of
this it was also important to realize
that Assad by what he did in his country
allowed Isis to move into it was then
Iraq al Qaeda in Iraq into Syria and get
strongholds and recruit that was the
work in support of Putin who is Trump's
best buddy so you can say Trump and his
friend Putin are the founder of Isis
which probably would be more accurate
than calling out the commander in chief
in that way stop stop you sound like a
[ __ ] because you are so think about it
Donald Trump goes out there and you know
basically stabs himself in the gut
repeatedly is like Obama founded Isis he
founded it he's the founder he founded
it crooked Hillary co-founder co-founder
co-founder
says over and over and over when Trump
goes and does interviews people offer
him an out and give him nuanced you it
was like I get recently created the
vacuum and you know maybe arm the wrong
people yada yada and bad decisions led
to Rises he's like no wrong founded he
found it yeah so I totally get the
critique that Kyle is is uh putting in
here right which is it's insane that
Donald Trump insisted that Obama founded
Isis even when some right-wing talk-show
hosts try to soften it or explain it or
given you once or whatever so it's a
total missed opportunity when then
Claire McCaskill goes and says oh you
know you could also make the case that
it's actually Trump and Putin who
founded Isis I get it Lois right the
idea is if you were going to try to lend
credence to the idea that Donald Trump
that Barack Obama founded Isis you can
just as easily create a harebrained and
terrible explanation as to how in some
way the actions of Putin and in some way
Trump as his quote buddy also
participated in founding Isis I get the
idea I get the sort of thought
experiment that Claire McCaskill is
using there but it's just terrible
because that clip then can then be used
against her and against Democrats and of
course against Hillary so I totally get
what she was doing you're on Fox News
right it from up from a practical
standpoint big mistake to go with that
direction yeah but we get that uh that
there are a lot of connections in that
to global politics and and uh policy can
be confusing and complex and all dilated
interrelated yeah you're on Fox News you
have to be extra extra careful you're
walking on eggshells and I would say no
matter what channel she was on this is
not really an analogy she should have
used not really a game she should have
played but particularly when you're on
Fox News and chris wallace say whatever
you will about his political biases and
I'm not completely clear on what they
are at this point but he is a good
interviewer who generally speaking
unless there's some kind of obvious
reason he's staying away from a topic
will grill you and he will make you note
look not good so I think this was a
strategic mistake by Claire McCaskill
although I get the idea
and Kyle kolinsky / secular talk
completely all over this and you can
check out his full commentary by
clicking the link in the video
description below